[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace cono Sur desde
Uruguay en el programa del día de hoy
hablaremos sobre la intensa sequía que
vive el país que ha provocado más de dos
años de pérdidas en el sector agrícola
que además aquíbrantado la seguridad
alimenticia y ha agotado reservas de
agua para consumo humano
abordaremos también la buena temporada
estival que vivió el sector turístico
con gran afluencia de visitantes pero
que debió ajustar la rentabilidad para
ser competitivo en la región
desde 1940 no se vive una sequía tan
intensa en Uruguay
por tres años consecutivos las lluvias
son de baja intensidad y muy poco
frecuentes el instituto uruguayo de
meteorología informó en Febrero que el
60% del país registró sequía extrema y
que la totalidad del territorio estuvo
bajo sequía el Ministerio de agricultura
y pesca evaluó las pérdidas en 1.100
millones de dólares para sectores de
ganadería lechería y agricultura la
reserva de agua se han acabado los
cauces han cortados cauces importantes
para Uruguay han cortado sus sus
cauces de sus caudal por lo tanto esto
habla de que es un fue va a ser una un
golpe grande para Uruguay los más
afectados han sido los productores
ortofrutícolas donde incluso
plantaciones de más de 70 años de
antigüedad se han secado prácticamente
por completo y creo que la pérdida en
horticulturas prácticamente que entre un
70 y un 90%
de la pérdida no sólo de producción de
este año sino de años siguientes las
plantaciones de peras y manzanas que
logren sobrevivir La sequía no darán
frutos por casi dos años y reponer
aquellas que se secaron conllevará cinco
años recuperarlas situaciones similares
se repite en otro tipo de frutas y
hortalizas como tomates pepinos y
lechugas lo que impacta directamente en
la seguridad alimentaria del país que
Uruguay va a tener que importar frutas y
verduras sin duda porque el golpe es
grande me Temo que mucha gente muchos
niños de Uruguay no van a poder comer su
Manzana supera O su durazno como debe
ser y como es habitual no
este y bueno nosotros vamos a estar
fuera del mercado por un tiempo los
productores deberán afrontar Los costos
de mantener sus plantaciones vivas por
dos años pero al no tener frutas no
recibirán ninguna ganancia el gobierno
uruguayo facilitó herramientas
financieras para que estos accedan a
créditos blandos pero muchos afirman que
es un riesgo que no están dispuestos a
correr esta situación para nosotros un
crédito un salto al vacío
porque
no sabemos ni si lo vamos a pagar muchos
productores señalan que su mayor
incertidumbre son los cambios que ven en
el clima que no responden a los ciclos a
los que estaban acostumbrados les
preocupa informes como el de World
weather atribution una red de
científicos climáticos que demostraron
que las sequías pueden ser
desencadenadas o exacerbadas por cambios
en el transporte de la humedad
atmosférica provocada por la
deforestación de los bosques amazónicos
del Sur ocurrida en 2020 es casi como si
fuera una ruleta
es muy compleja la situación de qué es
lo que se viene porque nunca sabe si
bien venimos de años complicados con
falta de agua pero lo que venga de aquí
para adelante no nunca lo vamos a ver
porque capaz que hoy en día es la la
falta de agua una sequía capaz que el
año que viene como pasó hace 10 años en
el 2013 fue una manga de granizo
imprevista
y vistes es muy complejo Y aunque Un
verano seco y cálido fue un duro golpe
para el campo la industria turística se
vio beneficiada pese a los altos precios
uruguayos muchos lo eligieron como su
destino para vacacionar bueno el balance
de la temporada en un contexto regional
bastante negativo sobre todo por la
situación económica financiera del tipo
de cambio en Argentina nosotros podemos
decir que el balance es muy bueno si
bien las cifras oficiales de la
temporada se darán a conocer pronto el
presidente de la calle Pou Indicó que en
enero ingresó al país un 10% más de
turistas que en 2019
varios analistas estiman que dicho
aumento se mantuvo durante todo el
verano
sin embargo los operadores turísticos
señalaron que sus negocios no han sido
tan rentables como en otras temporadas
estivales Lo que pasa que nosotros los
hoteleros estamos viviendo una situación
particular que es que
no pudimos acompañar las tarifas en
cuanto a la evolución de los costos
digamos no O sea si si comparamos los
costos en dólares trasladamos los
dólares a pesos no de hace dos o tres
años antes de la pandemia todos los
costos en pesos subieron a en términos
de dólares no nosotros tenemos hemos
podido lograr llegar a a valores
parecidos de antes de la pandemia pero
los costos han subido en relación mucho
más el reto es desestacionalizar el
flujo de turistas para que la industria
tenga un buen desempeño durante todo el
año es por ello que se continúan los
esfuerzos para fomentar el turismo de
convenciones cultural y de esparcimiento
como los casinos llegamos así al final
de enlace cono Sur desde Uruguay
continúe con nosotros en France 24 y
France 24.com